[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
jetzt kommt ja bald der fastenmonat
ramadan und bei meinen eltern und bei
uns ist so als immer wenn man bei meinen
eltern sind auch außerhalb des ramadans
dann kommt nach dem essen meist 80 ein
nachtisch und das ist dann immer helfer
erwarten ist so eine masse als es gibt
verschiedene arten von helfer einmal mit
chris einmal mit mehl das mit krise habe
ich schon auf meinem kanal mit mehl gibt
es auch in meinem türkischen kochbuch
und dann gibt es noch die variante mit
sesampaste also mithin und das ist so
die variante die meine eltern zu hause
immer haben aus der packung und ja
irgendwie ist meine mama bisher glaube
ich nie auf die idee gekommen das macht
selber auszuprobieren
also haben wir uns gedacht tüfteln wir
ein rezept aus und machen das einfach
mal selber ich habe jetzt hier meine
variante auch mit vanille mit schoko
noch mit dabei und natürlich pistazien
die finde ich so super orientalisch und
ich glaube alle in den optischen punkt
würde ich jetzt nach meinem helfer geben
aber nachdem wir das ganze zubereitet
haben problem wird es auch mal und dann
darf auch mal mein team probieren denn
hello hat so eine richtig also seltsame
konsistenz ich glaube auch in
deutschland das es da nichts
vergleichbares gibt das ist auch richtig
samt musik irgendwie anders aber
vielleicht könnt ihr das jetzt und
später beschreiben
ich zeige euch jetzt mal die wenigen
zutaten ich muss dazu sagen es ist keine
weight watchers rezept also bis ne fette
und der bisher letzter ist schon mit
dabei aber man ist ja auch nicht eine
ganze menge davon
also hier sind die zutaten für meinen
helm brauche ich 200 gramm butter 450
gramm mehl 200 gramm puderzucker 300
gramm sesampaste also dahin vanille
extrakt und pistazien das halloween es
ganz traditionell im topf zubereitet
darf man nämlich jetzt die butter und
kann sie erst einmal vorsichtig
schmelzen lassen
jetzt kann ich hier vorsichtig das mehl
einrühren und darauf wird so eine art
mehlschwitze gemacht
und jetzt wird diese mehlschwitze
solange angebraten bis sie so leicht
bräunlich wird und bis auch der milde
geschmack verschwindet also es dauert
jetzt auch wirklich so etwa 10 bis 15
minuten und dem ist wirklich ständig
rühren währenddessen und dann kommt der
richtig tolle geschmack zustande
ihr könnt die masse auch gerne wenn ihr
zu hause habt mit der kern wird cooking
chef kumi machen die erhitzt nämlich bis
180 grad und da können das einfach da
reingeben und wirklich fünfte
minutenlang rühren lassen
die mehlschwitze wird zuerst ein
bisschen heller und dann wieder dunkler
und bei dem vorgang müsste wirklich sehr
geduldig sein und wirklich auf mittlerer
stufe arbeiten denn ansonsten verbrennt
das mehl
so hat jetzt die perfekte farbe also
sandfarben jetzt kommt der puderzucker
dazu und wird auch noch kurz ein gehört
jetzt kann ich die masse vom herd
herunternehmen ich lass uns ist jetzt
drauf aber ich habe dein herz aus und
jetzt bitte ganz ganz vorsichtig
arbeiten damit nicht auf eure haut
spritzt jetzt kommt nämlich dass dahin
rein also die sesampaste und wird dann
gemeinsam mit dem wandel extract
vorsichtig eingerührt
und jetzt so lange rühren bis die
glöckchen verschwunden sind
jetzt hat echt um den typischen helvar
geschmack und ich merke auch schon die
helfer konsistenz
und jetzt kann ich hier noch die
pistazien einigen ihr könnt aber auch zb
walnüsse verwenden die passen auch ganz
gut
und wer möchte kann einen teil davon mit
paco verrühren für ne kako variante
dafür nehme ich jetzt einfach etwas
kakao und verrührt es mit dem tal hin
und färbt und etwa ein drittel davon
damit ein
bei mir kommen jetzt hier durch die
stadt ziehen noch rein aber auch welche
und den rest teppich auf das kommt dann
nämlich noch obendrauf
jetzt kommt die masse in eine form rein
und wird dann gepresst wird sie später
schön raus gestürzt werden kann ihr
könnt jetzt zum beispiel auch so ein
glas verwenden
einfach eine form eurer wahl ich
verwende jetzt in der kastenform und
habe die mit frischhaltefolie
ausgekleidet damit ich das später wieder
rausbekommen
und jetzt kommt ein bisschen von der
hellen masse ryan dunn von der dunklen
masse und da kann ich das ein bisschen
vermischen
[Musik]
jetzt lasse ich so abgedeckt bei
zimmertemperatur abkühlen und dann kommt
noch mal für zwei stunden in den
kühlschrank
[Musik]
nach der kür zeit konnte ich jetzt was
hell war ganz einfach aus der form
heraus stürzen und dann in scheiben
schneiden und so ist es auch im
kühlschrank wirklich sehr lange haltbar
murat ich glaube wir machen jetzt eine
blindverkostung also ich schneide
schönste was ich drauf gehen und sie ist
es eher links ist gekauft
ja damals schon überlegt ob es
vielleicht abgelaufen ist aber so
spricht der farbe nach zu urteilen
und da kommen alle gäste mal richtig
überraschen was ja auf jeden fall weil
ich glaube die meisten kenntnis hat nur
gekauft
ich bin ich auch anderes messer und ich
würde sagen damals ihr dürft mal
fotografieren würde ich schon sagen ihr
dürft mal probieren link wo kommst du ja
eben ist jetzt ja auch so machen
komm nach linz iwf jedoch ist dieser
batteriepack tja wie erstmals nicht
produzenten schließen
das machen wir hier bauen hier voll die
spannung war race ist wohl okay was er
nicht sagt nichts sagen du darfst den
markus nicht beeinflussen
ok jetzt kommt variante 2 22 22
ja ja die zwei war seitz gemacht was
hatte ich bei der 11 bei der castingshow
das schmeckt als atome in drei jahren
das nummer post nicht legen stück weg
und da kann es noch mal klein und
schmeckt echt super g und die konsistenz
halt so was ganz eigene
es gab es schmeckt auch der deutschen
bevölkerung also marius hat gesagt was
schmeckt euch auf jeden fall
und dann könnt ihr das rezept gerne zu
bereiten für eine ramadan finde es cool
weil man es halt wirklich morgens
vorbereiten kann oder schon tage im
voraus
im kühlschrank lagern und dann einfach
runter schneiden
samira ist es echt gern aufs brot getty
macht sich das ja dann auch so mal und
am tag auf's brot und nach dem essen
sagt mein papa halt immer muss man das
essen weil das tut es normal dass es
darunter drücke das wasser sagt mir dass
alle türkischen weiß aber den deutschen
saison drücken
papa sagt immer hellwach ethisch wie
sagt er immer je mehr basteln oder
irgendwie so dass 100 drücke basalt satt
wird
ich weiß halt nicht erstaunlich dass ist
na ja manche sachen hören sich halt
komisch an aber schmecken tut's auf
jeden fall gut probiert gerne mal aus
das rezept findet ihr auf sullivans
blog.de ich wünsche euch viel spaß dabei
beim nachmachen und wir sehen uns wieder
das nächste mal
der job
halt stopp jetzt tätig bevor ihr
abschaltet wurde jedoch bescheid geben
diese woche samstag also am 2 juni 2018
werde ich nämlich in wien da gibt es
eine signierstunde und zwar im hummer
eleven das ist ein einkaufszentrum und
wenn ihr vorbeikommen dann freue ich
mich wir sind von 14 bis 16 uhr da nur
quer weil ich will auch dabei sagt dass
ich dabei unser wein vielleicht kommen
noch mehr leute da
also ich würde mich sehr freuen denn wir
machen jetzt eine österreich-tour und da
starten wir in wien sind war und
ansonsten sind wir leider nur noch
privat unterwegs
aber wir nehmen alles für euch auf also
wenige vorbei kommt am 2 juni 2008 10 14
16 uhr humor eleven in wien mit spar
interspar ja oder ein anderes video
anschauen
[Musik]